what's up everyone welcome back to the
cinema center at marble at Tiff 2023 I
am talking to the filmmaker behind the
end we start from Mahalia Bellow huge
congratulations on your movie a very
very ambitious story to tell with many
many layers that I feel like we don't
see in very many apocalyptic narratives
out there thank you congratulations all
right so because I clearly know what the
movie is but this is where you're
introducing it to the world our viewers
will not know much about it just yet so
can you give everyone a brief synopsis
of the film oh God okay yes I can
um so the film is called at the end we
start from and it's a a story about a
woman who has her first baby just as a
flood consumes London and parts of the
UK and it's about her journey through
that new landscape and as her journey as
a new mom it's a very very good
description I also like asking the
filmmaker for a synopsis so I know where
and to stop and not spoil anything and
go too far I mean you know I don't know
yeah I have a quote I wanted to ask you
about when when it comes to signing on
the film because I had read that it was
one of your producers had said that when
you were approached for the project that
you read and loved the script and you
were very clear with what you wanted to
do with it so it was making me wonder
when you read it what were some of your
top priorities the things that you
thought you could bring to the project
that maybe no other director out there
could have I think when I when I first
read it I read the book
um probably quite soon after my first
child I'm a mum and it stuck with me it
kind of deeply stuck with me and sort of
stuck in my gut but I I wasn't sure
whether it was adaptable if I'm honest
and then Alice Birch wrote this
beautiful script and I think
um when I read it and also I think I
knew that this film was it's completely
it would have to be completely its own
tonally and it had to talk about the
internal world of new motherhood and let
the outer World
um
mirror that in some ways so try and flip
it around in in some ways
um so for me I wanted to talk about what
it would be to be a hero in the really
true and honest and earthy way
um that you know we really talked about
that yeah some of the greatest real real
world heroes are mothers even without an
apocalyptic scenario yeah yeah it's true
isn't it yet another quote for you I
want to talk a little bit about your
experience working with Alice because
another thing that I read is when you
were developing the story together
someone said are different modes of
Storytelling felt like a really
interesting mix so I want to know about
that too what were those different modes
and what was it about them that paired
well together I mean Alice is is a
really beautiful formal writer I mean
when she writes dialogue or writes a
moment in a scene and she manages to
really find a Truth by kind of turning
it around on its head in some ways
um and she's she kind of uh is like uh
like she sets a scene and it's very
clean and clear and I think I'm uh a
little bit more lyrical like so between
us this kind of poetry mixed with a kind
of coolness of Alice I think is I mean I
I really loved working with her and I
really loved that Dynamic and that kind
of merging of two flavors you know right
some of these next questions I feel like
might lean towards towards Megan but
yeah I did want to ask a little bit
about the idea of pairing the themes of
motherhood that you're exploring with an
apocalyptic scenario what is it about
this flood and the climate crisis that
you think enhances the point you want to
make about being a mother I mean it's
that's a very layered question isn't it
it's a big question like the whole movie
it is the whole movie I think there are
so many elements of this there's this
idea of tomorrow about bringing people
into the world and what you want from
the world
um but there's also the the shifts that
happen when you become a new parent that
you yourself
change you know you you are there for
someone else you know fathers and
mothers and you have to shift yourself
to meet that and you see the world in a
whole new way
um
so I think I felt like the parallels
between Parenthood and a world changing
around you and having to kind of really
navigate that
um was so kind of compelling you know
very very much as the other question
that is kind of leaning towards Megan
but also you opted to keep this in your
film as well I'm always fascinated by
naming conventions with characters just
in general I find it fascinating even
when characters have more traditional
names here your main character is woman
and then every other character is
represented by an initial why do you
think naming the characters that way
enhances the experience I think well
it's something that happened in Megan's
novel she she did that and I think it
helped to focus the story so completely
on who what woman was thinking which is
about the baby
um but for us I mean we toyed with the
idea do we change it you know do we and
we I spoke to Jody about it and we
decided not to it made things slightly
different local you know how many
letters can you think of for various
characters but actually what it ended up
doing was it meant that the actors could
bring their own character and they could
name I think it give ads a secret to the
story like what is the character's
actual name and that a secret for an
actor is called isn't it it's like
something they can hold on to I don't
want you to reveal their secrets but do
you know the names they came no no not
at all
but also I think it adds a universality
to the whole thing for sure I did want
to ask about your collaboration with
Jody so
first maybe what is something about her
as an actor and the way she likes to
collaborate with her director that
helped you exceed your own expectations
for your work as the Director of this
film
um uh so Jody is outrageously courageous
as an actor
um and for me
one of the most beautiful things is I've
never felt I mean I don't want to be
generalized but she she gave me a lot of
trust which was such a gift for a
director and I think she was a partner
in this whole process from beginning to
end and um journeyed with me through the
whole thing and she as an actor is so
clever I mean the way she deals with
every scene and the babies she's just
she's just a brilliant
um
uh she carried this character completely
and so beautifully you know I have many
many follow-ups at first because you
just uh refer to her as being clever can
you maybe pinpoint a moment on set when
you know she brought something
unexpected to a scene and the scene and
your plan for it evolved because of it I
mean there are lots of moments all right
I have to think of something really
specific now
I mean there was something
the way I like to work is the script was
so beautiful but there was also moments
of improvisation that would naturally
happen especially because there was a
baby involved and when I say clever I
mean present and Jody is incredibly
present so if the baby was doing
something she would naturally react to
react to the baby but also there's a
gutsiness to what she does you know and
in this film she had to go to places and
she wanted to do that and I think
um sometimes that kind of like tenacity
as an actor is being incredibly Brave
and yeah now I want to go back to the
trust thing can you give me an example
of a time answer when you could feel the
trust that she was placing in you and
that's the reason that the scene worked
I mean I think
I think for me so so Jody hasn't had a
baby so a lot of the way through this
this whole journey had to be from not
just me but other people in life but I
had to make sure that the reality of
that was held and so she was looking to
me quite a lot for that and trusting me
that it was was right and she gives
birth at the beginning and that's a very
particular experience and
um and for her to have to kind of um
create that authentically it was really
important to both of us and you know and
I was there hopefully holding her
through that
collaboration I'm Stellar you feel it
while you're watching the film I have to
talk about some of your other cast
members here too I want to talk about
everyone I wish we had time for that
today to at least get to two people can
you maybe give me an example of two
actors you worked with on this film that
have unique approaches to their work
where it calls for something different
from you as an actor's director it's so
interesting is it because every actor
has their own process and there's
something really interesting so uh Joel
Fry
um is a a really really present and
really instinctive he is a um he plays a
woman's partner in the story he plays a
character called R the initials again
but he um
he's quite a funny man he's hilarious
you know when you're around him he's
he's absolutely hilarious and he um
picks up on everything so what was
interesting actually which was really
great was seeing he is brilliant at
improvisation he's completely there in
the moment and would throw Jody moments
so there's a moment when we see them in
the past at one point and this date
scene that happens I don't want to give
anything away but there was moments
where he could just see her just have to
react to him being so charming and funny
with her so that was that was great
because that was a very they would have
different modes of of Performing
completely but it worked
um and then who else oh yeah Catherine
Waterson
yeah Catherine
um I think I very when I first spoke to
her I gave her this note that was just
like if you had an argument in a shop
you'd be the kind of person
who'd walk down the aisle holding both
hands off knocking everything down and
from there she just spun this character
out that brought this life and this
energy
um I'm very thankful to her because I
was very nervous about how that
character it was so important such a big
it's another romance in some ways you
know in the whole significant energy
shift with their character too and it's
not easy to make that character feel
like she's part of the same scenario
same film but also add that new energy
to the piece and yeah she Nails it yeah
she does yeah I think she she also would
throw there's one moment in the film
um which was Catherine where she saw on
Jody's face that she had an eyelash and
that was just completely
Catherine being completely alive to the
moment and she she takes the eyelash off
and says make a wish and it was just
this connection that the bond that they
created through that was wonderful I do
that all the time and seeing something
just like little day to day like that
represented in a film like this
especially this kind of scenario I feel
like that's that's a big contributor to
what makes this whole thing feel real
and grounded and connected about the
connections between people which is what
I thought was really important there's a
I guess a personal uh question because
whenever I watch apocalyptic movies and
you know usually they're like big
blockbuster movies where I hate phrasing
it this way but it's almost fun to think
like can you survive a zombie apocalypse
this is this is a little different
though so having gone through the
process of making the movie has it made
you yourself rethink how you might react
to such a situation or maybe is there a
particular character that your thought
your thought process might align with
the most in terms of how they react to
the flood I don't think we all know how
we'll react but I also think that it's
happening and people are and it's
potentially incoming in some ways
versions of this and I I think we don't
know how I react but I hope that we will
bond together and make these connections
and move through so speaking of the
current climate crisis it's been a high
priority talking Topic at this point for
like way too many years but it does feel
like that conversation is like Amplified
intensified more and more every single
day so given how much has changed even
from the beginning of making the film to
the end is there any current events or
actual reactions people were having to
The Climate crisis that impacted how you
depicted the flood I mean in this in
this instance I think we
we made sure that the point of view was
particularly through the kind of
subjective internal lens so that almost
our flood was an internal view of the
world and so we yeah we related it more
to Motherhood but I think
um
you know the world is Shifting around us
and I hope it resonates and doesn't
terrify but adds some hope to the world
in some ways as well when you are making
a movie like this you go in I'm sure
plan to a t so that you could get
everything done that you want to get
done but in making any movie things
things go awry things don't always go
according to plan according to schedule
can you give me an example of a specific
day on set when things didn't go to plan
you had to find a creative way to to
Pivot find a solution and you did and
because of it you found unexpected magic
that makes a move even better I feel
like the film is a lot of that I mean
it had to be organic because we had a
baby on set pretty much in every scene
you know there's something that happens
when when you have uh someone who
doesn't play ball but is so integral to
the story they're acting in a completely
different way one of the key things that
kept happening was so in rehearsal
um we brought in a newborn baby and
um Jody I don't think it had much relate
of a relationship with newborn babies
particularly and so her hand was shaking
when she picked up the baby
I'm so nervous and it was perfect
because for me at first I was like oh no
oh no but then I realized that's exactly
how I was when I held my first child but
what was annoying was that as she got
through the film she became really good
with babies so she would always put them
to sleep she'd just be rocking them and
instead of having this baby that I
wanted awake in the scene it'd be like
muzzling up falling I was like stop
rocking stop rocking you know given that
did you uh have the opportunity to film
this in sequence oh no yeah I don't
think so that's a luxury most movies
don't yeah no sadly not
um that would have been amazing but we
did we I mean because of the babies and
the development and because we did a
fair bit of that you know you see the
babies change like the babies change
every day it's fascinating so did you
film with a real baby every single step
of the way or was there ever part where
you had to have a substitute I mean you
don't want to give that away but yeah I
mean sometimes but we would have a baby
there it would be because the baby had a
nap or couldn't you know we would always
have a baby for us available to us
um yes so creatively it was quite
important because it changed completely
the performance like they would they
would it was so
um
instantaneous the reaction and both Joel
and women how they reacted when the baby
was there was its own thing to when it
wasn't you know it's one of the first
Lessons Learned in film school never
make a movie with a baby you made a
whole movie with a baby for my sins
um I will wind down with two of my
favorite questions so you make a really
ambitious movie here very successfully
having come out the other side are there
any goals you had or maybe new goals
that have emerged that feel more Within
Reach than ever because you accomplished
this because this movie exists oh wow
I mean
it felt like a birth this film for me
um it's my first feature and
I mean it's been a dream since I was 10
so I think I'm just sort of sitting with
this moment for a bit tomorrow we're
screening for the first time with an
audience and I'm hoping to experience it
all take it all board all on board
um after this I don't know I want to
just keep making movies and um
yeah and keep doing what I love and
making the internal external no all
right I'm gonna squeeze in two more
questions now because I want to follow
up on that because I really didn't bring
up the first uh the first time feature
filmmaker thing at all I am curious when
you first realized you had a dream to
make a feature film what did it look
like and how does it compare to the film
and the specific story and themes you
wound up pursuing I think this is very
true to what I imagined the film to be
it's taken a while to get there you know
it's been it's been hard but also
beautiful and I feel like I
I've been like I have been making things
before and slowly tuning in a voice that
I would want to sit in a cinema the
Church of the cinema and see
so I feel like this is close to that
reality it's close to
my insides in some way so given that
this is something I always love asking
about it's it's important for any
filmmaker at any stage of their Journey
but in particular someone getting the
trust and the necessary powers to make
their first feature their way can you
maybe pinpoint someone or maybe a
company on this production that you know
you felt trusted you and trusted you to
make this movie your way and you hope to
have more collaborations like that in
the future well
um Sunny March
um trusted me so much and
um and Leah Clark their producer was
just my right hand woman she was amazing
and the BBC and the BFI they they
championed me and I I feel very thankful
to them all and lies and Liza Marshall
as well from hero pictures I mean it was
a group of women
um who when I set out to make this film
in the way I wanted to make it got what
I was talking about and um had moved
through that Vision with me and held me
through it I have High Hopes that's
going to continue and this Premier
audience is going to very much get what
you're talking about and also feel the
fact that this film feels specifically
like unique to a filmmaker and couldn't
have been brought to screen the same way
by anyone else on the phone I mean it
the Ethereal expressivity that you feel
while watching something like this is
very very palpable so congratulations on
the movie everyone out there do not miss
it keep an eye out for it and also stay
tuned we will have more conversations
for you from Tiff 2023 very soon